hey guys I'm just McDonald it is a 20
second of January and your children to
gamespot years let's dig into all that
pain YouTube is for praise drama from
yesterday's show yesterday it was
revealed that Microsoft was giving
machinima produces a monetary incentive
to portray the xbox one and it's games
in a positive light machinima and
Microsoft have responded to the reveal
by saying it's just a typical
partnership the joint statement from
Microsoft and machinima was basically a
justification combined with a cop-out
and a wall of babe microsoft said they
had no idea that machinimas contrast
existed while machinima said usually
these promotional videos required that
the content creators identified the
promotion which they weren't allowed to
do this time around and machinima are
shocked as to why this was not the case
I guess they didn't read their own terms
and conditions aside from that EA has
its own promotional program called
roncar which does more than just bearing
a very sort of name it consists of
YouTube users being paid to publish
video content for battlefield 4 and need
for speed rivals obviously the promotion
does seem to be pretty typical practice
but the issue for you guys and for the
Federal Trade Commission no less is that
these promotions are supposed to be
overt and transparent whereas in
practice they all seem to be blanketed
down into secrecy under confidentiality
agreements what do you think of the
promotional program and do you think
more companies are in on it let me know
next up everybody's favorite developer
CD Projekt RED who says that the witcher
3 would have been impossible for ps3 and
xbox 360 CEO mrsa Nowinski said that had
it been developed for last generation
consoles it would have been a smaller
game that wasn't open world with poor
loading times and graphics sacrifices
sound eerily similar to any other last
gen console games you've played Witcher
3 is however coming to ps4 and Xbox one
which speaks pretty well to the power of
the new consoles in fact a winski said
that the difference between
these console versions and the pc
version isn't even that huge since the
new generation consoles are what he
refers to as brand new pcs let me know
which platform you'll be using to
venture off into the realm of the
witcher 3 later this year last up today
Microsoft loves naughty dog which is
probably a tad unrequited since the last
of us dev is a sony own studio Microsoft
Xbox exec Phil Spencer has said the
studio is special and unique and noted
their amazing track record his comments
came in response to a question over what
the Microsoft equivalent of naughty dog
would be now that Bungie has regained
its independence too expensive replied
they aren't interested in making a
studio that's like another studio they
just want to cultivate a group of great
first party studios let me know if you
prefer the first party studios of either
Microsoft or Sony in the comments down
below or on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald that is pretty much everything
I've got for you today but do remember
to hit that subscribe button if you
haven't already entered back with me
tomorrow for what is very likely to be a
bunch more news and just McDonald and
I'll see you soon